o único confronto valerá muito bom
começar pela primeira vez como nunca
antes do vídeo aviesp cuidado no estudo
como assim
o lado pessoal de quem fala é o lugar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago já que joga óssea é
beta 0.1 sendo bom com vocês podem vir
aqui neste manual neste item o fred eo
boliche e um fox está tudo completo ou
está tudo certinho e porquê porque eu
tive que ontem à tarde inteira achar
esta [ __ ] para conseguir passar os
níveis por quê perguntou vocês vocês
repararem que no canto inferior direito
vocês têm um menu que lhes é estranho eu
sei que vai dar um quarto secreto ou
qualquer coisa assim torcida eu não vi
muito bem mas curso
vamos explorar e esse pessoal espera
calma calma se eu espero apenas que está
eu acho que ele vai ficar muito curto
muito pequeno portanto vamos fazer uma
coisa diferente vamos tentar voltar a
jogar um dos mapas jogos coletivo do fox
e assim e vamos lá então jogar aqui o
faccini bounty o burnley que maior a
pensar fosse eu acho que foi uma hora
passar o chica ou imagens 20 minutos a
passar o fred foi qualquer coisa assim
até fui rápido freire e bora lá jogar o
fla xxi e já começou a já esqueci me
esqueci meu esquece né que assim que eu
posso ser e foi sorte a calma calma
calma agora vai parar
pronto agora vai agora sim o jovem
thomas müller na fica aí foxy fica aí
mas não parece que os objetivos e agora
o botafogo já no preço já é difícil
porque já computei foto cinéma o meu
cozinho está relaxado exato não aqui mas
coisas pra apanhar
eu acho que tem que iniciar este nato
fox e não entende nem tênis boxe eu acho
que não vou pilotar oscar isso não é
porque já computa aí olha vai transmitir
a encarar nessa altura eu tenho que dar
a volta
tem um botão de reis vou questionar o
fla ele e vou cantar em ras al khaimah
não pára por aí que eu vou fazer
desapareceu o botão do extra não o caen
calma calma vamos não calma do ano
felipe ok agora vamos ter que voltar a
puxar o freio e pretende o botão do
extra importante eu e você mesmo
obrigada passaram agora está outra vez
de atum rabilho fred
bora bora um objeto que já corre corre
vai vai o estudo mapeou mais fácil do
que estou dizendo é que o projeto vai
com o time que o flamengo fosse [ __ ]
o meu agora tá bom é difícil encontrar o
cara já tá me faltam dois fatores hoje
em dia nos fundos
a rádio vai vai eu acho que faltou um
posto aqui ontem e punham impostos aqui
vai vai conectar a primeira vai apanhar
uma vontade podem viajar por seu tio
através do botão 23 foi muito rápido
relatou que um produto já está assim há
dois pontos que todos fez dois mas vamos
lá então o que interessa pessoal embora
eu a jogar aqui o nosso é estranho é o
[ __ ]
o globo tentou exata eu vim até aqui
exatamente uma sala do museu us 4 e
marrone que só tem e chica teonila o
fred eo fox está tudo exposto
olha suína preta do fox e um empréstimo
com um cartel para ele não sair agora o
que eu tenho que fazer até que modelos
[ __ ]
alô alô taí a belo arranjo olhos ou boca
dela tinha uma pedra tinha uma armadilha
duros sabem pra ela aí está o cheiro
boca começou no caminhão china boca utah
foca é único assim o cheiro acho agora
eu não vou expor nenhuma eu tenho foi
feito em flashing lights in assim vai
perceber que uma porta à eu acho que
esta foi a porta que entrei pra [ __ ]
o o otto vai dar a volta e isto isto vai
dar acha que vai avançar eu vou lançar
eu não tenho medo dos faxinais da
michelin para olha só estão cururupu não
consigo
a eterna linda pra trás não vai jogar
vai só ganhe tudo o que possuo eu não
sei preciso de uma coisa o flush por mim
eu estou sentindo é pintada aqui vai
saber se o futuro é cortar tudo tá farto
eu não sei explicar o que está a
acontecer
eu tô eu durma sentido voip é isto mas
avançar mas avança só avança só vejam só
a diferença entre ter a luz acesa e
apagada ó faz qualquer diferença ou ou
não escorrer entramos pra não sai tão
oportuno porém não aceita aqui ouviu
ferir hoje e agora tem que voltar atrás
e colocou o caso sob a aliança militar e
também qualquer coisa é uma porta né
[ __ ] conta que o frei não foi a noite
só foxes bruera isso a foc eu tenho que
seguir os fogos seja isso é porque não é
por onda tutorial é que o tutorial já
encontrei é porque o caminho e não sair
juntos o puto to aqui por recurso ao
agora só por isso vou fazer o boxe fight
night só eu sou eu que digo que as leite
leite não rima com frango mas depois
veio preto eu não disse que como banana
mentira é um segredo e eu também tem um
canal e ela disse que o metrorec nos
meus mentira para enganar e da sua banda
do sol que eu sou preto multa mesmo a
todos a pistola búfala liga e até a
próxima